احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
نويهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه ابرز
العناوين
في باخمه تصريحات لا تقل سخونه عن المعارك
زيلينسكي يتراجع بعد اقراره بالسقوط
وفاكنير ستغادر المدينه في 25 من مايو
عشيه دخول وقف الهدنه حيز التنفيذ في
السودان طرف الصراع يتعهدان بالالتزام رغم
استمرار المواجهات
وازمه سقف الدين تعمق الخلافات بين البيت
الابيض والجمهوريين وبايدن قد يلجا
للدستور لتجاوز الكونجرس
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا من فلوريدا
حيث يستعد رائده الفضاء السعوديه على
القرنه وريان برناوي للانطلاق في اول رحله
تاريخيه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه نتابع
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله تكمل ان كان
صعوبه التدريبات على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه من اهداف الباحثين
او العلماء والمطورين اللي على الارض
يجلبوا تجاربهم هذه في الفضاء دوري الان
هو اني امثله في هذه المهمه العلميه هذه
التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا من
القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وتعد هذه
البعثات الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه
ويوصل طموحنا لعنان السماء
هذا هو يستقر القرني وبرناوي في هذه
الاثناء داخل مركبه دراغون التي تستعد
للانطلاق من جزيره ميريت بولايه فلوريدا
المركبه دراجون 2 والتي يحملها الصاروخ
فالكون تسعه ستتجه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه لاجراء اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه
علميه وفي لقاء خاص مع قناه العربيه تحدث
رائد الفضاء السعودي على القرني عن مهامه
في الرحله المتجهه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه نتابع مقاله
سوف نقوم باجراء سته تجارب في الطب البشري
وهذه التجارب تعنى بدراسه التغيرات التي
قد تصيب الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام
وكذلك النظر هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها
في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه
سوف يتم استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في
الفضاء بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه التجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمرار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخضراء وشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
وقال القرنين العربيه انه خضع للكثير من
التدريبات قبل رحله التاريخيه للفضاء
ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى يتم
تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد اتمنى
مؤخرا الجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزي الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات وجمله على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
هذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا
من القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وكذلك
بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود الى ارض
الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف المرجوه من هذه
الرحله
بها وصفات رائده الفضاء ريان برناوي في
حديثها
وصفت مشاعرها بعد اختيارها ضمن المهمه
العلميه الى الفضاء لتصبح اول رائده فضاء
عربيه ومسلمه تصل للفضاء
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه البط حق المختبر حقي
وخلاص طالعه من البيت رايحه على دوامي
يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء سعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه ولا انا الان رائده فضاء او باحثه
ما صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحب عملي
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا اسكن في
الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص اللي
مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده كنت
حابه اني اقول لها الخبر وهي في جده
فطلعت على الغ رفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت تذكره من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذه الخبر
العظيم
من جانبه عبر والد رائد الفضاء على القرنه
العربيه عبر سعادته بهذا الانجاز حيث ثمن
الجهود التي تقوم بها المملكه وولي العهد
السعودي ضمن رؤيه 2030
المشاعر يعني ابدا فخورين جدا ومبسوطين
جدا والحمد لله وهم يمثلون المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وهم نتائج الرؤيه المباركه رائد محمد بن
سلمان الله يوفقه ويعزه الملك سلمان وهذا
نماذج الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
شكرا لكم شكرا للعربي
وطبعا العربيه تتابع لحظه بلحظه
الاستعدادات لهذا الانطلاق من الان ينضم
الى من فلوريدا مراسل العربيه حسين الطاو
من هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء بالرياض مراسل
العربيه هاني صفيان سابدا معك حسين يعني
اقل من ساعه تقريبا
وينطلق علي وريان الى الفضاء في هذه
التجربه وهذا اليوم التاريخي بالنسبه
للسعوديه اطلعنا على اخر الاستعدادات في
هذه اللحظات
تحيه لك ميسون بالفعل بعد ساعه وتسعه
وعشرين دقيقه سينطلق الصاروخ الذي يحمل
مركبه دراغون وفيها رواد الفضاء الفضاء
ومعهم علي وريانا هي لحظات ترقب ما قبل
هذه الرحله المهمه
بعدما عشنا لحظات حماسيه عندما وصلوا الى
كيف كنبرا الى مركز كندي قبل نحو ساعتين
واكثر واستقبلوهم ولوحوا لاهاليهم ولوحوا
لنا كان هناك لحظات من الافتخار من قبل
اهاليهم بهم الان الرائدان هما في قمره
المركبه بعدما الجرياء الترتيبات الاخيره
اثراء تسلمهم من قبل سبيس اكس التي تتكفل
باخذهم الى هذا الصاروخ واجراء اللمسات
الاخيره من فحص القلب بالذات الفضائيه
الخاصه بكل رائد فضاء هذا ما عرفناه هي
بالذات خاصه بكل شخص تناسب
مشاكل كبير بشكل جيد كان متعاونين جدا
طبعا الترتيبات التي سبقت مجيئهما اليوم
كانوا يتلقون التدريب في هيوستن في تكساس
هناك تدربوا على محاكاه
اقامه التجارب في المحطه هناك نسخه من
المحطه الفضائيه يتم تدريب فيها رواد
الفضاء الذين سيذهبون الى هذه المحطه
يتعلمون كيف يمكن ان يتعاملوا مع حالات
الطوارئ كيف يتعاملون مع
ادوات هذه المحطه وايضا عندما تكون
المركبه تصعد الى الفضاء كيف سيتعاملون
معها هذه المركبه تقود نفسها بنفسها بشكل
تلقائي لكن رائدي الفضاء
الامريكيين هما قد يتدخل اذا كان هناك
حاله طارئه لقيادتها
كما بات معروفا هناك 14 تجربه
هذه التجارب وهذه هذه هي العمليه وهذه
المهمه هي باكوره مهمات مستقبليه تحدثت
الى المدير
مدير مكتب التكنولوجيا في شركه اكسيوم
سالته ان كان هناك رحلات بالمستقبل اكد لي
ذلك وقال لي بان هناك ايضا الدول العربيه
الاخرى ربما ستشارك فيها كذا برامج هذا
هذه الرحله هي خطوه اولى لهيئه الفضاء
السعودي
لتعزيز الكوادر البشريه الوطنيه السعوديه
لكي ترفض صناعه الفضاء السعوديه في
المستقبل ولكي تكون رواد فضائيه يستطيعون
خوض رحلات قصيره وبعيده المدى طبعا اضافه
الى توقيع اتفاقيه اكسيم
مع وكاله ناسا التي تهدف ايضا الى
الاستفاده واستكشاف الفضاء واستكشاف سطح
القمر والمريخ واضافه الى الكويكبات
الاخرى اضافه الى اعاده الانسان الى سطح
القمر حسين اسمح لي ان نذهب الان الى هاني
الصفيان طبعا في السعوديه انت متواجد عن
قرب مع كل الموظفين الذين ايضا قلوبهم
دادوق عيونهم شاخصه لهذه اللحظه التي
ننتظرها بعد ساعه ونصف من الان لانطلاق
رائدي الفضاء السعوديين نحو الفضاء هذا
الهاشتاج الذي عمى تويتر اليوم اخبرنا
اكثر هاني كيف هي الاستعدادات كيفيه
الاجواء في هذه اللحظات الحاسمه اذا يمكن
وصفها
صحيح على هذه الشاشه قبل قليل كان السيد
ابراهيم الكثيلي وهو مدير المشروع اطلاق
رواد الفضاء كان يتحدث ايضا من هناك من
فلوريدام على هذه الشاشه التي فيها هذا
المكان الذي نقف فيه وهو مركز الموحد
لمهمه اطلاق رحله الفضاء السعوديين
لرايدي الفضاء السعوديين طبعا كان يتحدث
عن بدايه المشروع وكيف بدا وكيف ايضا كان
هناك طواقم واعداد كثيره من هيئه
الاتصالات او هيئه الفضاء والاتصالات
والتقنيه كان يقومون بهذا العمل هنا
تحديدا في مركز المركز الموحد الذي يراقب
فيه اعداد كبيره من الشباب والشابات
مهندسين ومهندسات اخصائيين واخصائيات
وتقنيين وتقنيات ايضا يقومون بمراقبه
اللحظات الاخيره تبقى لدينا ساعه و 23
دقيقه وكل ما مر الوقت الثواني تنقص وتتجه
الى الدقائق وبعدها تتجه الى هذه الساعه
التي تنقضي او سوف تنقضي خلال الساعه
المقبله وبعدها سوف يتم اعلان او سوف يتم
اطلاق الصاروخ طبعا رايدي الفضاء وكذلك
الرائدين الاخرين موجودون هم جميعهم على
متن هذه الكبسوله وهي مركبه دراغون وعلى
على الصاروخ فالكون طبعا في هذه اللحظات
يتم مراقبه ايضا من منسوبين والمنسوبات
هنا في هيئه الفضاء والاتصالات والتقنيه
العمليات الاخيره التي هي من مهام عملهم
مرتبطون مباشره مع مركز الموحد في فلوريدا
وكذلك ايضا من خلال الشاشات المرئيه
والشاشات التقنيه مرتبطه ايضا ببعض مراكز
المراكز الموحده في المملكه اذا نحن نتحدث
هنا عن ابن القوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه وهو علي القرني وابنه ايضا
مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي للابحاث ريان
برناوي وهي عالمه الابحاث وكذلك التي تحمل
او هي اخصائيه وابحاث مختبرات وهي تحمل
بكالوريا او معها بكالوريوس علم الانجاب
والهندسه الوراثيه وايضا ماجستير علوم
طبيه حيويه من جامعه الفيصل ولديها خبره
تسعه اعوام هي تحمل معها بحوث علميه نتحدث
عن 14 بحثا علميا منها بحوث طبيه سوف
تشارك فيها اكثر من 12 طالبا في السعوديه
عبر تسعه واربعين مركزا وموقعا في
السعوديه سوف يشتركون مباشره مع هذه
البحوث العلميه والعلام ابن القوات الجويه
الذي ايضا لديه او يحمل ايضا خريج او هو
نقيب برتبه نقيب من القوات او خريج الكليه
الملك كليه الملك فيصل الجويه وكان ايضا
على متن المقاتله اف 15 اس ايه ايضا سوف
يقوم بعمل هذه الابحاث بجانب ريانه وايضا
بجانب الطلبه والمواقع التي حددتها
السعوديه في 49 موقعا خلال الاثنى عشر
يوما القادم في مقابلات سابقه كان قال على
القرني انه الصعود الى الفضاء والذهاب الى
الفضاء شيء صعب جدا ولكن ليس مستحيلا خاصه
بانه هناك رؤيه في السعوديه خاصه رؤيه
2030 التي تساهم بشكل كبير
لتطبيق او لتحقيق هذا الطموح وهذا الحلم
دائما سنكون معكم زملائنا هاني طبعا سنعود
اليك خلال هذه النشره او في النشرات
اللاحقه انت كنت معي من هيئه الاتصالات
وايضا الفضاء في السعوديه ومن فلوريدا
اشكر مراسله العربيه حسين الطاوود الذي
ايضا سنتابع معه هذه اللحظات لانطلاق رواد
الفضاء السعوديين الى الفضاء شكرا لكما
اذا مشاهدينا طريق صعب وشاق ينتظر ايدي
الفضاء السعوديين الزميل نايف الاحمري
يعطينا عرضا افتراضيا عن هذه الرحله كيف
ستبدا ومتى ستنتهي ودائما بتقنيه الواقع
المعزز نتابع سويا
هذا ليس صاروخا يستخدم في حروب العصر
الحديث انه تالكون تسعه ذلك الصاروخ الذي
ينقلنا الى ابعد رحلات استكشافيه في الكون
وربما في اهم رحلات التنقيب عن اسرار
الفضاء وحل الغاز هذا الصاروخ مشاهدينا
تلتصق فيه مركبه دراغون التي نراها هنا
سيكون علمتني دراغون اول امراه سعوديه
تحلق نحو الفضاء ريان برناوي وعلي القرني
رائد الفضاء السعودي يقومان برحله الى
الفضاء الخارجي لزياره محطه الفضاء
الدوليه رفقه اثنين اخرين ضمن مهمتي
وهذه اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء لفريق رواد
سعوديين لتدشن المملكه عصرا جديدا في
استكشاف الفضاء وعلامه فارقه للحدث
التاريخي تعالوا معنا مشاهدينا لنص عذاب
الى الفضاء افتراضيا طبعا لكن حذاري انها
ليست كاي رحله الوصول الى الفضاء وحده
يستغرق نحو 24 ساعه قبل التحليق لابد
لرواد الفضاء من المرور بمراحل عتاب
وتدريبات مكثفه واختبارات حاسمه وهذا ما
مر به علي وريان بالطبع حيث خضع لكافه
البرامج التدريبيه التي تساعدهما على
اتمام هذه المهمه بنجاح واجراء التجارب
العلميه المتعلقه برحلتهما الى الفضاء
تبدا الرحله فعليا مشاهدينا بالصعود على
متن مركبه دراغون اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه
تنقل البشره الى المحطه الفضائيه تصل
حموله المركبه الى اربعه ركاب من والى
المدار نشاهد الركاب هنا في استديو
العربيه لكنها قادره مشاهدينا ايضا على
اعاده كميات كبيره من الحملات الى الارض
لنستعد اذا لمرحله
الاطلاق
بعد انطلاقه من المنصه يصل الصاروخ لسرعه
الصوت ولا ننسى مشاهدينا ان الصاروخ يمر
باعلى منطقه ضغط هوائي ديناميكي
وبالارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا تتم عمليه
الانفصال الاول بعد سبع دقائق وحين يصل
لمدار الارض المنخفض يتم الانفصال الثاني
بعد ذلك ترتبط مركبه دراغون بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه هذه هي محطه الفضاء الدوليه في
هذه المرحله مشاهدينا يقوم الطاقه بمركبه
دراغون بعمل مناوره باستخدام الدافعات حتى
يتم الاقتراب والالتحام بالمحطه
ها قد وصلنا مشاهدينا اذا الى المحطه في
هذه الرحله سيجري رواد الفضاء السعوديون
14 تجربه رائده في الجاذبيه الصغرى بما
فيها تجارب توعويه تعليميه يشارك فيها 12
الف طالب وطالبه واثنان واربعون موقعا في
السعوديه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مهمات
كثيره ولافته بانتظار علي وريان في الفضاء
ونحن هنا على الارض ننتظر عودتهما من
الفضاء سالما
ولدينا في اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات المانيا
وكوريا الجنوبيه تتفقان على تعزيز التعاون
الدفاعي لمواجهه استفزازات كوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
نكمل الاخبار الساعه مشاهدينا من اوكرانيا
تحديدا من الشرق فعقب اشهر من النكسات في
ساحات لاعنف واشرس المعارك بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه روسيا سيطرت على
المدينه وبعد اعلان سقوطها اعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيس كان المدينه الاستراتيجيه قد
تكون خرجت فعلا عن سيطره قواته قبل ان
يتراجع لاحقا حيث قال ان المدينه ليست
محتله ومع ذلك فالمعركه الاطول والتي وصفت
بمفرمه اللحم تكبد فيها طرفان خسائر فادحه
ولا سيما على الصعيد البشري لكن السؤال هل
تستحق المدينه كل هذا العناء بعض
التقديرات الغربيه والاستخباراتيه اشارت
الى مقتل ما بين 20 الى 30 الف روسيا في
المدينه في حين تتحفظ موسكو عن ذكر
خسائرها في ساحه المعركه تضاف الى تلك
الارقام الكلفه العسكريه ولا سيما
والنقائد
افاجنررا خلال الاشهر الماضيه القاده
العسكريين الروس مده بالدعم العسكريه
اليوم يقومون بمهمه بالغه الاهميه وهم في
باخموت حتى اليوم ولكن لن اخبرك في اي
موقع بالضبط لكن هذا يعني ان باخموت لم
يتم احتلالها من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
يبدو النبات تحولت من مكرمه لحم الى مفرمه
تصريحات فقائد
فاغنريكوتين رد على تصريحات زيلينسكي وقال
انه لا يعلم ما يحدث على الارض
لم يبقى في ضخمه اي جندي اوكراني لاننا لا
نجد من يمكننا اخذه في الاسر وهناك عدد
كبير من جثث الجيش الاوكراني زيلينسكيماكر
اوليس على علم بما يحدث على الارض
في الاثناء
ستسلم سيطره ضخمه
في 25 من الشهر الجاري مؤكدا ان قواته
استولت على كل الاراضي التي وعد
بالاستيلاء عليها حتى اخر سنتيمتر وافقت
تعبيره
مشهد يطلق عليه اسم انتصار مدينه تطلبت
224 يوما من الصراع المحتدم بين فاجنر
والقوات الاوكرانيه ليرفع الروس علامه نصر
بارد بطعم خساره كل ما في المدينه
لكن الانتصار المفترض ياتي في ظل صوره
رماديه ونزاع على تبني الانجاز وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه كتبت كلمه النهايه على
احدى اطول معارك الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا باعلانها السيطره التامه على
مدينه بخمت من قبل قوه فاغنر
على اثر الاعمال الهجوميه لوحدات فاغنر
بدعم من مدفعيه وحده وطيرانها اكتمل تحرير
مدينه ارتيموفسكي
عمل يستحق الشكر من قبل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي هنا الوحدات المقاتله
وقوات الجيش التي قدمت الدعم لها بحسب
وصفه شكرا قد لا يبدو ذا اهميه بالنسبه
الذي اشار الى جهد فاجنر المتفرد في
المعركه مصنفا للجيش الروسي الى فئتين
يحترم الاولى منها لما قدمته من دعم شحيح
واخرى وصفها بالمشلوله على حد تعبيره
استغرقت العمليه للسيطره على باخموت 224
يوما فاجنر وحدها كانت هنا
وبينما يتقاسم الروس اسباب النصر واطرافه
تنكر السيطره الروسيه على المدينه بالاصل
اعلان السيطره على بخموت ليس الا وسيله
يغطي بها حجم الخسائر التي طالت قواته
وبالرغم من تصريحات
في قمه مجموعه السبع والتي تعكس واقع
الخساره في بخمه الا ان مسؤولين اوكران
يصرون على ان وحدات الجيش تحاصر المدينه
بشكل شبه دائري
لم يتبقى شيء هناك باخ متباقيه في قلوبنا
تضارب في التصريحات من طرفي الحرب يوحي
بان الواقع قد يكون انقلابا للادوار بينما
يوجد داخل المدينه ومن يحاصرها واذ كانت
معركه بخمه مشكوكا في اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه ستصبح نهايتها ايضا مشكوكا
عمر العربيه
ورغم اعتزامي باكثر التسليم بخمه للقوات
الروسيه الا ان معارك المدينه سلطت الضوء
على ما وصفته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز بالاداء
الشخصي بين بريجين والقاده العسكريين
الروسي والسيطره على المدينه الاوكرانيه
تمثل انتصارا سياسيا لزعيمر الملقب بطباخ
بوتين
فبراير الماضي ظهر الخلاف لاول مره بين
بريكوجين ومسؤولين الدفاع الروسي والذي
زادت حدته لاحقا وصل حد اتهام وزير الدفاع
بالخيانه وبحسب وثائق الفندقون المسربه
فان الخلافه قد تفاقم بينهما لدرجه ان
بوتين تدخل شخصيا بعد ان دعى الاجتماع بين
بريجوجين
ولاحقا اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعاونها
الا ان بيجوجين استمر في توجيه الاتهامات
والانتقادات لاقادتها العسكريين بشكل علني
من موسكو معي مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الروج عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا اخر
التحديثات حول هذا التضارب بالمعلومات
اوكرانيا ما زالت مصره بانها لم تسيطر
روسيا بالكامل على بخ ماذا عن الجانب
الروسي
مساء الخير ميسون بيان وزاره الدفاع
الرسمي النهائي في نهايه اليوم تطرق
للحديث ان بخموت الان تقع تحت السيطره
قوات فاغنر بالكامل كل الجيوب التي يدور
الحديث عنها وتواجد لمقاتلي الجيش
الاوكراني فيها جميعها تقع في اطراف
المدينه مجموعه الصحفيه ميسون كانت قد
نشرت مقاطع فيديو مختلفه من ارجاء مختلفه
من المدينه يعرفها جيدا المنطقه هناك حسب
التقارير الوارده طبعا مقاطع هذه الفيديو
تظهر رفع العلم الروسي في العديد من
المناطق ورفع علم مجموعه فاجنر في اعلى
نقطه في المدينه ما دفع طبعا القوات
الاوكرانيه حسب التقارير الوارده من هناك
الى استهداف هذا المكان بقذائف هاون ميسون
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه كل الاوساط السياسيه
الرسميه في البلاد تتحدث عن السيطره على
لسانه الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع مجلس الامن
وغيره من الشخصيات الرسميه في الدومه ومن
الشخصيات التي تقوم بتحليل الوضع سياسيا
وعسكريا معظمهم يتحدثون عن السيطره لقوه
على مدينه السؤال الاكبر الان عبد الجواد
الرشد يقول في الخامس والعشرين سيسلم باخت
للجيش الروسي ولكن السؤال الان هل سيبقى
هذا الخلاف بين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وبين
فاجنر ماذا سيكون مصير فاجنر وخاصه ان
الرئيس الروسي قال بانه سيكرم كل من ساهم
في جعل بخموت تحت السيطره الروسيه
سابدا مع بمصير فاجنر ومجموعته وقواته
طبعا قبل نحو ساعه من الان خرج وتحدث في
اخر مقاطع اليوم يتحدث بانه في حلول الاول
من يونيو يعني بعد قرابه تسعه ايام من
الان لن يكون هناك اي مقاتل واحد من قوات
فاجنر على الخطوط الاماميه جميعهم سيتركون
مواقعهم وسيذهبون لاعاده التهيئه
والتدريب والتعافي من جديد تحدث بان هذه
المجموعه مجموعه فاغنمر لم يتم تحريكها
الى اي مناطق جديده ايضا تحدث بانه سيقوم
بتسليم كافه المواقع بحيث ان مقاتلي فاغنر
يخوضون هذه الحرب منذ
428 يوما اما اليوم فهذه المهمه اصبحت من
مسؤوليه وزاره الدفاع يؤكد في اخر مقاطع
الفيديو اليوم لان قواته لن تكون في خط
المواجهه
الاول اعتبارا من الاول من يونيو القادم
شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه كنت ناعم
موسكو
خطا قليله مشاهدينا باتتفصل اوكرانيا عن
تحقيق رغبتها في الحصول على مقاتلات افسته
عشر الامريكيه الحديثه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه كشفت عن تفاصيل حزمه المساعدات
العسكريه الجديده لاوكرانيا التي اعلن
عنها الرئيس جو بايدن خلال لقائه نظيره
الاوكراني طبعا على هامش قمه مجموعه السبع
في اليابان حزمه المساعدات هذه تعد السحب
الثامن والثلاثين لاداره بايدن للمعدات
العسكريه من مخزونات وزاره الدفاع منذ
اغسطس لعام 2021 كما انها جاءت لتلبيه
الاحتياجات الامنيه والدفاعيه لاوكرانيا
والتي تصل قيمتها الى 375 مليون دولار
وتشمل ذخيره لانظمتها
وقذائف مدفعيه ومركبات مدرعه
[موسيقى]
تواصل الولايات المتحده بذل كل ما في
وسعها لتعزيز قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
نفسها بما في ذلك اطلاق بعض الجهود
المشتركه الجديده مع شركائنا لتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على الجيل الرابع من
الطائرات المقاتله مثل اف 16 وهذا الاسبوع
مجموعه السبع فرضت ايضا مئات العقوبات
الجديده وضوابط التصدير ضد روسيا لضمان
استمرار الضغط على بوتين لمحاسبه مؤيديه
عن هذه الحرب
السؤال الان ما هي العقبات والتحديات التي
تواجه كياف وحلفائها فيما يتعلق بمقاتلات
اف 16 فالتحديات اللوجستيه تكمن في انك قد
لا تتمتع بالسيطره الكامله على مجالها رغم
ان انظمه الدفاع المضاده للطائرات التي
تمتلكها تمنع الطائرات المقاتله الروسيه
من القيام بعمليات خارج خط المواجهه هناك
تحدي اخر وهو انخفاض مخزونات الاسلحه
الغربيه ولاسيما الاسلحه المضاده للطائرات
بالاضافه الى الخدمات اللوجستيه المكلفه
رغم ان كاف قدمت وعودا لواشنطن بعدم
استخدام اف 16 داخل العمق الروسي لكن لا
تزال المخاوف من تصعيد محتمل قائمه في حال
لجات كاب لهذه الخطوه وينظر لهذه الصفقه
المحتمله على انه قد تسهم في قلب الموازين
حيث ستقدم
ميزه تنويع المهام الجويه وفرض السيطره
على الاجواء بالاضافه الى حمايه المشاه
على الارض في هجماتها المضاده كما ستعمل
الطائرات كنظام واحد مدمج مع الدفاع الجوي
الارضي ما يسمح لك باسقاط الصواريخ
الروسيه التي تستهدف بها موسكو المنشات
الحيويه الاوكرانيه
لدي ادله قاطعه من زيلينسكي بانهم لن
يستخدموا اف 16 للمضي قدما والانتقال الى
الاراضي الروسيه لكن اينما كانت القوه
الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا والمنطقه سيستطيعون
القيام بذلك
[موسيقى]
منذ 30 عاما اجتمع المستشار علا تشولز
برئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
اجتماع نتج عنه تعهدا بين الزعيمين بمزيد
من التعاون في انشاء سلاسل توليد صناعيه
مستقره ومواجهه المخاطر النوويه التي
تشكلها كوريا الشماليه رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه اكد ان مكانه الشراكه في سلسله
التوريد ستساعدهما في التعامل مع تنامي
عدم الاستقرار في الاقتصاد العالمي
والصراعات الجيو السياسيه كما شدد على ان
الدولتين ستعملان على تعزيز العلاقات
التجاريه بالاضافه الى استكشاف المزيد من
الفرص في مجالات التعاون الدفاعي وفيما
يخص كوريا الشماليه اشاره يون الى انه
وشولز قام بتوجيه رساله ثابته الى المجتمع
الدولي مفادها بانغ ليس لديها ما تجنيه من
استفزازاتها التي وسطها بغير القانونيه
[موسيقى]
سنعمل معا لتحقيق التشغيل السادس لسلسله
امداد الصناعات الدفاعيه من خلال التوقيع
الفوري على اتفاقيه بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والمانيا تهدف الى حمايه المعلومات
العسكريه السريه سنوضح انه لا يوجد شيء
يمكن ان تكسبه كوريا الشماليه من
الاستفزازات غير القانونيه وسنواصل ارسال
رساله الى المجتمع الدولي والعمل معا بشكل
وثيق من اجل نزع السلاح النووي لكوريا
الشماليه
اخبار الساعه نتابع بعد قليل ايطاليا
تواجه اسوا فيضانات منذ قرن
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه من الشان السوداني
فارغم اتفاق الهدنه والذي مقرر ان يدخل
حيز التنفيذ مساء الاثنين تجددت
الاشتباكات اليوم بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع حيث وقعت مواجهات متقطعه بالاسلحه
الثقيله بين طرفي الصراف الخرطوم ووسط
وجنوب ام درمان اما في غرب البلاد
وبالتحديد في مدينه نيالا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور اسفرت الاشتباكات عن مقتل اكثر من
60 مدنيا ومئات الجرحى فضلا عن خروج جميع
المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه من الخدمه
واسفر الصراع حتى الان عن قرار اكثر من
مليون شخص سواء داخل البلاد او الى الدول
المجاوره ما اججج ازمه انسانيه تهدد
بزعزعه استقرار المنطقه
لا يلتقي
في الاثناء اكد الجيش السوداني التزامه
باتفاق الهدنه الذي جرى التوافق عليه في
جده وقال المتحدث في بيان انه يامل ان
تلتزم قوات الدعم السريع بالاتفاق لكن
الجيش اضاف ان الاتفاق يتضمن فقط الجوانب
العسكريه والفنيه ولا يشمل المسائل
السياسيه من جانبها تعهدت قوه الدعم
السريع الالتزام بالهدنه وقالت انها ستعمل
على تسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وفتح
الممرات للمدنيين
ولكن ماذا تضمن هذا الاتفاق الجديد بشان
وقف اطلاق النار في السودان والذي وافق
عليه طرفان نزاع بمحادثات جده تضمن وقف
كافه الهجمات والاعمال العدائيه بما في
ذلك تجميد الهجمات الجويه او استخدام
الاسلحه الثقيله الاتفاق تضمن ايضا حمايه
كافه بل حمايه كافه المرافق الطبيه
والمستشفيات والامتناع عن استخدامها
للاغراض العسكريه كما نص على وقت اعمال
النهب والسلب والتخريب واي اعمال تتعلق
بالاخفاء القسري او الاحتجاز التعسفي
للاشخاص واتعهد الطرفان بالامتناع على
التحريض واستخدام اي مجموعات قبليه او
عرقيه في الصراع الدائر كما يمنع الاتفاق
تقييد او اعاقه حركه المدنيين بمن فيهم
العاملون في المجال الانساني او استخدام
المدنيين كدروع بشريه
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده حيث لا زالت ازمه
سقف الديون الامريكيه تشكل عبئا كبيرا على
الاداره الامريكيه فالمحادثات وصلت الى
طريق مسدود مع تبادل الاتهامات بين البيت
الابيض والجمهوريين الطرفان سباقا مع
الزمن لتجنب احتمال تخلف الولايات المتحده
عن سداد التزاماتها بعد الاول من يونيو
يشترط الجمهوريون ان يوافق بيضا على خفض
كبير في نفقات الميزانيه مقابل موافقتهم
على رفع سقط الدين ما دفع الديمقراطيين
الاتهامهم باستخدام تكتيكات لدفع اجندتهم
السياسيه معرضين الاقتصاد الامريكي للخطر
ومع ذلك هل الباب لا يزال مفتوحا لتجاوز
هذه الازمه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وصف
مقترحات الجمهوريين بشان سقف الدين بغير
المقبوله ومع ذلك قال انه بالامكان التوصل
الى اتفاق هذا واعلن البيت الابيض ان
بايدن وزعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
كاظم
سيلتقيان اليوم لمواصله لمناقشات حول سقف
الدين ومع ذلك قد يلجا بايدن في النهايه
الى استخدام الماده الرابعه عشره من
الدستور لتجاوز في حال استمرار الخلافات
لقد قمت بدوري طرحنا اقتراحا يخفض الانفاق
باكثر من تريليون دولار بالاضافه الى ما
يقرب من ثلاثه تريليونات دولار لخفض العجز
الذي اقترحته سابقا من خلال مزيج من خفض
الانفاق والايرادات الجديده الان حان
الوقت لان يتحرك الطرف الاخر من مواقفه
المتطرفه لان الكثير من ما اقترحه بالفعل
هو ببساطه وبصراحه تامه غير مقبول
من جانبها حذرت وزاره الخزانه من عواقب
وخيمه اذا نفذ النقد من الدوله
لتفسقاقاتها ما سيجعلها غير قادره على دفع
رواتب الموظفين الفيدراليين ويؤدي الى
ارتفاع محتمل في اسعار الفائده لكن هل
الازمه اقتصاديه بحته يشير تقرير لصحيفه
ولس الى ان الازمه السياسيه وليست
اقتصاديه في المقام الاول فرفع سقف الدين
عمليه روتينيه اساسا لكنها اصبحت في
السنوات الاخيره محور خلاف مع المشرعين
الجمهوريين ساعين الى الحصول على تقليص
للانفاق في مقابل رفع السقف المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض اندروبيت اتهم الجمهوريين
بالسعي لاحداث ركود في الاقتصاد الامريكي
لم يتوقف البيت الابيض عند هذه الحجج انما
قال ايضا انما كارتي يتعرض للضغوط من
التيار المؤيد لدونالد ترامب في حزبه
الجمهوري مجله نيويوركر الامريكيه قالت ان
الصراع القديم المتجدد بين معسكر
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين هو مجرد علامه
على الخلل الوظيفي الشديد في واشنطن وهو
تذكير ايضا بان السياسه الامريكيه الفاسده
تشكل ازمه جيوسياسيه بالاضافه الى ازمه
داخليه
[موسيقى]
الان الى تركيا سبعه ايام فقط امام
المتنافسين على الرئاسات لاقناع الناخبين
الذين لم يمنحوا ايا منهم منهما اصواتا
كافيه لحسم الدوره الاولى في منتصف مايو
الجارد الرئيس المنتهيه ولايه تهرج الطيب
اردوغان حصل على
49.52% من الاصوات اي بتقدم يبلغ مليونين
وخمسمائه الف صوت على مرشح المعارضه كمالك
اما ممثل المعارضه الذي وعد بالعوده الى
الربيع والديمقراطيه الهادئه لم يقنع اكثر
من
44.9% من الناخبين الذين ادلوا باصواتهم
وسيتنافس المرشحان بشده على اصوات مليونين
و790 الف ناخد اتجهت لصالح المرشح الثالث
سنان اوغان الذي سيعلن لمن سيجير اصواته
في الايام القليله المقبله نتائج الجوله
الاولى مشاهدينا من الانتخابات التركيه لم
تاتي على مستوى تو المعارضه لكن اردوغان
تمكن من الحفاظ على مكانته رغم نتائج
استطلاعات الراي فيما يسعى الطرفان الى
جعلها لحظه نصر ما قناعتهما بضروره تغيير
استراتيجيتهما لحسب المعركه النتائج
الطفيفه بين اردوغان وكليتشاردلو منحت
المعارضه املا في تحقيق مفاجاه لكن ما هي
خطه
بحسب صحيفه فاينانشيل تايمز فان المعارضه
بدات تلعب بورقه القوميه لحمل الاتراك على
الانتخاب لصالح لكن ذلك ينطوي على مجازفه
وفق بعض الاراء حيث تحول خطابك من الحديث
عن الربيع الذي ينتظر تركيا الى خطابات
وصفت بالعدوانيه تجاه اللاجئين حيث تعهد
بطرد المهاجرين حاله فوزه
اظهرت لقطات جويه حجم الاضرار في منطقه
اميليا رومانيا حيث ضربت الفيضانات التي
وصفت بالاسوا في ايطاليا منذ قرن متابع
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت نذكر بابرز العناوين
رائد الفضاء السعوديان عليه قرني وريان
برناوي يستعدان لدخول التاريخ باول رحله
من نوعها الى الفضاء
[موسيقى]
في باخمه تصريحات لا تقل سخونه عن المعارك
يتراجع بعد اقراره بالسقوط وفاقنا ستغادر
المدينه في الخامس والعشرين من مايو
وعشيه دخول وقف الهدنه حيز التنفيذ في
السودان
طرفا الصراع يسعهدان بالالتزام رغم
استمرار المواجهات
ازمه سقف الدين تعمق الخلافات بين البيت
الابيض والجمهوريين وبعيد قد يلجا للدستور
لتجاوز الكونجرس
اشكر لكم في المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات